Mass Effect Andromeda is just a few
months away but some of you lucky gamers
will get a chance to play at first I'm
Tony and this is your special access
gamespot news update EA and origin
access members will be able to play Mass
Effect Andromeda on March 16 EA access
is the company's Xbox one subscription
service and origin access is the same
deal but for PC subscribers will be able
to play a 10 hour trial of the game with
progress that carries over into the full
release though we don't know if those
ten hours will let you explore the full
game it also seems that this trial will
leave ps4 players out in the cold but
since EA access is not available on that
platform it's to be expected but hey
there's always that promise multiplayer
beta Mass Effect Andromeda launches on
ps4 xbox one and pc on march 21st in
north america march 23rd in europe in
other mass effect news there won't be a
season pass for the game even though dlc
is expected to keep up with all the
latest on Andromeda you're already in
the right place